une quatrième vague épidémique et l'état
d'urgence décrété pour la troisième fois
ce vendredi au japon le nombre de cas ne
cesse d'augmenter
plus de 5000 cas par jour et une
pression hospitalière alarmante selon
les autorités le système hospitalier
confrontés à une situation sans
précédent les contaminations aux
variants hautement contagieux représente
aujourd'hui 80 % des infections à osaka
et 30% à tokyo nous avons par conséquent
décidé d'établir l'état d'urgence à
tokyo kyoto osaka et dans la préfecture
de hyogo globalement épargné depuis le
début de la pandémie
le japon connaît une circulation élevé
des variants qui a provoqué une
dégradation de la situation sanitaire
l'archipel a donc décidé de durcir les
mesures par rapport au deuxième état
d'urgence décrété en janvier dernier à
partir du 25 avril les établissements
servant de l'alcool devront fermer et ce
jusqu'au 11 mai les centres commerciaux
et magasins sont eux aussi concernés des
lignes d'autocars et de train pourrait
aussi être suspendu pour limiter la
mobilité de la population
si les autorités des départements
concernés sont susceptibles de limiter
l'accès aux rassemblements sportifs les
jeux olympiques d'été dont l'ouverture
est prévue le 23 juillet sont maintenues
la présidente du comité a annoncé des
mesures renforcées et la tenue
d'épreuves tests durant la période de
l'état d'urgence à jocelyne quel poste
en tant que comité d'organisation nous
ne pensons pas à l'annulation
nous pensons à la façon dont nous
pouvons nous préparer pour donner la
priorité à la sécurité et faire en sorte
que les gens pensent que l'événement
peut être organisé en toute sécurité et
qu'il souhaite qu'ils le soient c'est la
chose la plus importante
nous devons donner la priorité à la
sécurité et faire tout ce que nous
pouvons pour organiser les épreuves
tests
à cela s'ajoute une campagne de
vaccination qui ne démarre pas au japon
seulement un pour cent de la population
a été vaccinée en raison d'essais
cliniques supplémentaires demandées par
le gouvernement
le japon est également victime de
retards de livraison des délais à
rallonge d'autant plus dommageable car
ce jour seul le vaccin de pfizer est
autorisé au pays du soleil levant